rentrer dans un instant mon invité est
ministre délégué chargé du numérique et
il a décidé de s'attaquer enfin je
dirais au problème de l'accès libre des
sites porno aux mineurs et disons-le aux
enfants et parfois aux jeunes enfants
alors a-t-il enfin trouvé la solution
Jean-Noël Barrault que vous apercevez
derrière moi nous répond après ce sujet
de Mathilde Moreau qui vous explique
tout
une attestation numérique pour certifier
son âge c'est ce que dévoile Jean-Noël
Barrault dans les colonnes du Parisien
son objectif faire respecter la loi et
l'interdiction d'accès au moins de 18
ans aussi pornographiques cela
fonctionnera un peu comme un contrôle
demandé par votre banque lorsque vous
réalisez un achat en ligne sauf que ce
certificat de majorité sera anonyme cela
devrait passer par le biais
d'applications à installer sur son
téléphone ou encore par les opérateurs
télécoms qui connaissent l'âge de leurs
clients cette solution technique sur
laquelle nous travaillons pourrait être
utilisé pour faire respecter les limites
d'âge qui existent dans notre droit mais
qui ne sont pas suffisamment respectés
en ligne
car c'est bien sur ce point que les
associations de défense des mineurs sur
Internet se battent le problème c'est
que parallèlement au fait que les sites
pornographiques ne bougent pas et ne
fassent absolument rien depuis 2020
plein de solutions se sont développées
par l'élement ce qui fait que leur
posture de dire on ne peut rien mettre
en place parce qu'on ne sait pas qu'elle
serait la bonne solution et puis il y a
plein de choses mais c'est tellement
faillible tiens de moins en moins
puisque parallèlement la posture qu'ils
avaient en 2020 en 2023 trois ans plus
tard a l'air de la technologie
d'Internet évidemment il y a eu
énormément de solutions qui sont mises
en place le dispositif sera détaillé
dans la semaine par la CNIL et l'arcom
avant une mise en application en
septembre prochain
bonsoir Jeannel barreau d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes ministre
délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications ça
fait deux ans me semble-t-il que la loi
qui devait empêcher les mineurs
d'accéder au porno a été voté efficacité
jusqu'à présent 0 il faut dire les
choses telles qu'elles sont est-ce que
vous avez enfin trouvé le moyen pour que
les enfants n'aient pas accès à ces
contenus d'abord il faut rappeler que
nos enfants sont victimes en ligne
d'atteinte brutale alors innocence et et
alors intimité et que ma mission c'est
comme Ministre chargée du numérique
c'est de les protéger et il y a
effectivement un scandale un scandale
révoltant qui est que dans notre pays
dès 12 ans un tiers de nos enfants sont
exposés aussi de porno qu'à 15 ans deux
tiers de nos enfants sont exposés aussi
de porno alors que la loi vous l'avez
dit interdit d'exposer un mineur à des
contenus pornographiques sous peine de
75000 euros d'amende et trois ans
d'emprisonnement alors pourquoi est-ce
que cette loi n'est pas appliquée et
bien parce que jusqu'à présent il
n'existait pas de solutions sérieuses de
vérification d'âge ou en tout cas il en
existe certains qui n'étaient pas
parfaite mais que les sites pornos en
s'arrêtant derrière des arguments
juridiques de liberté d'expression de
respect de la vie privée non pas voulu
mettre en place si bien qu'aujourd'hui
il est encore possible pour un jeune
enfant d'accéder à ces sites à ces sites
pornos sans aucune définit coûtant que
ma ma conscience professionnelle je suis
allé voir tout à l'heure sur le site
porno le plus connu et alors de fait il
suffit de cliquer oui j'ai plus de 18
ans et vous avez accès à tout ce que
vous voulez là pour le coup il n'y a là
actuellement aucun contrôle pas le
moindre si vous montrez dans la rue à un
jeune enfant des images pornographiques
vous vous exposez à trois ans
d'emprisonnement 75000 euros d'amende
si vous êtes un site porno aujourd'hui
en France et que vous diffusez des
contenus et bien c'est c'est jusqu'à
présent vous n'avez eu aucune sanction
ce qui va changer ce qui va changer
c'est que
l'arcom et la CNIL qui sont là chargés
de réguler les médias l'autre de faire
respecter la vie privée on trouvait un
moyen d'établir un référentiel des
lignes directrices pour que des
solutions puissent être développées qui
soient robustes alors concrètement
expliquez-nous qu'il soit d'un côté
fiable c'est-à-dire qu'elle ne puisse
pas être facilement contournée pour que
l'on puisse emprunter la carte de crédit
ou autre solution de son
mais d'abord expliquez-nous comment ça
va se passer alors c'est pas l'état qui
va mettre en place cette solution les
autorités administratives indépendantes
que sont LARCOM et la CNIL vont et c'est
la loi qui leur a donné ce mandala
définir un cahier des charges pour ces
solutions et ensuite
les sociétés celles qui existent déjà
qui ont déjà commencé à concevoir ces
solutions pour devoir se conformer ok
mais vous allez quand même en dire plus
parce que bien sûr aujourd'hui la
solution la solution telle qu'elle sera
dessinée par tel qu'elle a été décidée
par l'acnil et la com c'est une solution
qui repose sur ce qu'on appelle un
double anonyme le Doodle anonymat c'est
quoi c'est que celui qui va vous fournir
l'attestation que vous avez plus ou
moins de 18 ans ça peut être par exemple
votre opérateur télécom mais ça peut
être tout autre tout autre tracteur ne
sera pas ce à quoi va servir cette
attestation il ne saura pas ce pourquoi
vous avez demandé
le site pour adulte que ce soit un site
porno mais il y a d'autres sites qui
sont réservés aux adultes ne saura pas
qui vous êtes
et c'est ainsi qu'on aura établi une
référence et qu'on aura fait référence
et que la France sera d'ailleurs le
premier pays du monde à faire réellement
appliquer que vous allez sur un site on
vous demande si vous êtes majeur ou pas
et pour le prouver pour prouver que vous
êtes majeur vous devrez quoi expliquer
enfin votre paix c'est votre banque ou
votre opérateur télécom qui dira que
vous êtes majeur le site porno vous
demandera de prouver une de prouver
votre majorité comme plus précisément de
de lui transférer une attestation de vos
18 ans libre à vous
au travers d'un système qui va être
conçu par des entreprises qui sont déjà
en train d'y pencher de d'obtenir cette
attestation auprès de tiers je parlais
des opérateurs télécoms mais il y en a
d'autres qui peuvent le faire on a parlé
récemment avec le CPF de l'identité
numérique le compte personnel de
formation les arnaques au CPF je pense
que c'est un centre de concitoyens on a
entendu parler et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a développé l'identité
numérique pour protéger le compte
personnel de formation bien l'identité
numérique comme l'opérateur télécom ils
savent quel âge vous avez ils peuvent
vous donner une attestation de votre
majorité mais cette attestation il ne
doit pas savoir ce à quoi vous allez
l'utiliser et le site porno quant à lui
ou le site réservé aux adultes quand
elle lui il ne doit pas savoir qui vous
êtes ni qui vous a fourni cette
attestation ce système fonctionne ce
système il va être expérimenté dans les
dans les prochains mois avant d'être
généralisé et je veux dire quand dans
les prochains mois non mais c'est dans
un mois ou dans un an dans les prochains
mois ce système sera expérimenté avant
de pouvoir c'est une première mondiale
donc il faut qu'il soit expérimenté j'ai
lu dans le papier du Parisien que vous
avez certainement lui hier que ça
existait dans plusieurs États américains
non ce qui existe ce sont des solutions
qui soit ne sont pas vraiment fiables
c'est-à-dire qu'elles sont facilement
pas vraiment anonymes soit pas vraiment
anonyme un délai quand même c'est que
dans les prochains mois disons un peu
vous allez voir cette solution être
expérimentée sur alors c'est anonyme de
site avant qu'elle puisse être
généralisée et elle servira d'exemple
parce que aujourd'hui la France est dans
cette situation mais la plupart des
autres grands pays du monde le sont
aussi et tout le monde est à la
recherche d'une solution pour protéger
les enfants parce que il n'y a pas que
les parents Français qui s'inquiètent
pour l'avenir de leurs enfants ce sont
les parents dans le monde entier qui
sont conscients on peut dire que vous
espérez que ça soit mis en place avant
l'été
ça sera expérimenté avant l'été donc on
parlait d'anonymat parce que vous avez
un problème avec le porno pour les
enfants pas avec le porno en général
c'est une liberté enfin vous considérez
que c'est une liberté dans l'espace
physique il est autorisé lorsque l'on a
plus de 18 ans de consommer ou de de
visionner des images pornographiques
sans que on conserve des des données sur
votre identité il s'agit simplement de
montrer la solution la solution c'est
vrai d'autres c'est vrai d'autres biens
et services dont nous resterions l'accès
aux mineurs pour les protéger je pense
en particulier à l'alcool quand vous
allez acheter une bouteille de de
champagne par exemple vous demande un ou
de bière ou d'alcool quel qu'il soit et
bien on va vous demander je pense c'est
tout à fait détourné et si votre
solution marche aussi mal que l'accès
des mineurs à l'alcool ça c'est pas
terrible l'accès aujourd'hui des mineurs
à l'alcool n'est pas restreint par une
vérification sérieuse il faudra si nous
avons avec succès comme je l'espère
restreint définitivement l'accès ou en
tout cas la diffusion à nos enfants des
images pornographiques peut-être
faudra-t-il s'interroger sur le contrôle
de l'âge pour l'accès à des sites de
vendre de produits alcoolisés dont nous
voulons aussi protéger nos trucs et
certains c'est que on en termes de
numérique nos enfants sont meilleurs que
nous bien meilleurs que nous vous dites
que cette solution sera suffisamment
robuste quand dépit de leur agilité
numérique il n'arriveront pas à la
contourner ils arriveront peut-être pour
certains mais ça n'empêche pas ça
n'empêche qu'il faut mettre en place ce
type de garde-fou d'accord vous dites
aussi que ça va être anonyme faut dire
les choses telles que en utilisateur
majeur devra montrer qu'il est mais vous
pouvez nous certifier que sa femme ou
son mari d'ailleurs ne sera pas au
courant qu'il a fait cette démarche et
donc il consomme du porno il ne devra
pas montrer qu'il est il devra
simplement dire tester qu'il est majeur
bien
je reviens à ce que vous disiez au début
que les mineurs consomment aujourd'hui
beaucoup de porno vous avez dit qu'il
commence jeune les le rapport sénatorial
sur le porno parle d'une genèse
biberonnée au porno et évoque une porno
pandémie on en est à ce point je crois
qu'on peut le dire quand on sait qu'il y
a deux quand on sait qu'il y a 2
millions de de d'enfants de moins de 18
ans qui visionne des images
pornographiques chaque mois dans notre
pays c'est ce que dit ce rapport
sénatorial qui a le grand mérite d'avoir
mis ce problème sous le feu des
projecteurs et bien on peut dire qu'il y
a une situation critique une situation
d'alerte les psy disent que c'est
vraiment très traumatique parle de viol
psychique quels sont les précisément les
traumatismes que ça entraîne ça peut
entraîner chez les enfants ou les
adolescents je ne suis pas sûr de
pouvoir y répondre car je ne suis pas un
scientifique mais il est effectivement
attesté il y a un rapport de du Haut
Conseil contre les discriminations qui
l'a montré encore il y a quelques jours
que nous avons une jeunesse qui exposée
très tôt beaucoup trop tôt à des
contenus comme les contenus
pornographiques ou à des contenus très
violents ça crée des dommages pérennes
sur les enfants très certainement même
s'il est peut-être encore tôt pour
pouvoir la tester avec certitude avec la
certitude des scientifiques mais
l'intuition des parents en tout cas
l'intuition l'intuition qui est la
mienne celle d'un parent de deux jeunes
enfants c'est que cette exposition elle
peut conduire effectivement à des
dommages irrémédiable sur la vie
affective et intime de ces de ces jeunes
personnes bien vous reviendrez j'espère
avant l'été pour nous expliquer si la
solution que vous avez trouvée
fonctionne ou pas on va parler de
Twitter je ne sais pas si vous avez vu
la Une de Match cette semaine est-ce que
vous savez qui fait la Une de Match
cette semaine c'est pas à Beyoncé c'est
même pas Zelinski la nouvelle star
mondiale c'est Elon Musk qui est érigé
au rang de méga de méga star j'ai une
question simple à vous poser est-ce que
vous estimez qu'elon musk est dangereux
Elon Musk c'est d'abord un entrepreneur
de talent puisque dans le secteur
automobile dans le secteur spatial il a
conçu des innovations qui qui ont
véritablement eu un impact très concret
sur ces secteurs en particulier
maintenant il a voulu s'essayer au
réseau sociaux avec Twitter le rachat
Twitter même s'il a eu une petite
période de regrets de doute et il faut
le dire ça n'a pas très bien marché il a
voulu réinventer est-ce qu'il est
dangereux
je ne sais pas s'il est dangereux je
crois que ce sont son expérience comme
entrepreneur dans le secteur de
l'automobile et dans le spatial montre
en tout cas il a pu délivrer des
innovations qui ont eu un impact bon sur
la question des réseaux sociaux on a
évidemment beaucoup plus vigilant
puisqu'il s'agit d'espace qui sont
devenus des espaces publics qui qui
participent à la vie démocratique et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on est
vigilant à ce que ce réseau social qui
est Twitter reste un lieu dans lequel
les la modération des contenus et est
faite et notamment parce que au niveau
européen sous présence
était libertariens il voulait moins de
moins de modération lui ce qu'il voulait
c'était de rationaliser en quelque sorte
de d'automatiser la modération et il
s'est rendu compte que c'était en
réalité beaucoup plus dur que ça n'avait
l'air et que au fond s'agissant de
communauté vivante il y avait une
dimension humaine à la modération dont
il ne pouvait pas rouler la supprimer il
a renoncé à la supprimer cette
modération humaine finalement il s'est
rendu compte que sa méthode le
conduisait dans le mur et d'ailleurs on
a vu que il a il a depuis quelques mois
cessé d'expérimenter des solutions un
peu un peu je dirais
un peu un peu innovante telle que celle
qu'il avait expérimenté au départ et qui
n'ont pas fonctionné puisque on a vu
dans les dans les premiers jours où les
premières semaines vous êtes proliférer
mais mais il y aura un
une je dirais un rendez-vous important
ok la conformité de Twitter avec ses
obligations européennes nouvelles
puisque l'année dernière pendant que la
France présidé l'Union européenne nous
avons pris un règlement qui s'appelle le
Règlement sur les services numériques et
qui désormais dit que toutes les
plateformes qui veulent s'installer ou
qui veulent être actives sur le
territoire européen devront se conformer
à des obligations beaucoup plus
restrictives que celles qui existait au
préalable en matière de modération de
signalement ou de recueil du signalement
des contenus indésirables et de retrait
de ces contenus indésirables ou illicité
et donc le juge de paix pour Elon Musk
et pour l'aventure d'Elon musk avec
Twitter c'est sa conformité avec avec
ses règlements quand je l'ai vu
des images de vous avec lui quand je
l'ai vu début janvier c'est la question
que je lui ai posée et il m'a confirmé
ce qu'il avait dit au président de la
République à savoir qu'il mettait tout
en oeuvre pour se conformer à ses
obligations nouvelles là on vous voit
avec lui je vais vous poser la question
de façon peut-être un peu provoquante et
Cash il a acheté Twitter cash justement
44 milliards d'euros il envoie des
fusées sur Mars il installe un réseau de
milliers de satellites en orbite autour
de la planète est-ce qu'il écoute
vraiment le ministre délégué au
numérique de la France qui est
certainement pour lui un pays entre
petits et moyens je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il écoute le ministre de la France
mais ce que je sais c'est que l'Europe
est le plus grand marché du monde et que
si Elon Musk veut continuer à pouvoir
faire du commerce dans l'Union
européenne alors il devra se conformer
aux règles que nous avons fixées et cela
je suis allé le lui rappeler on va
parler d'une autre star à la célébrité
récente mais mondiale également c'est
pas quelqu'un c'est un robot c'est
évidemment chat gipiti qui a une
question pour vous
alors il faut que je lis si on m'envole
synthé ça met le bonjour monsieur le
ministre du numérique au sujet
quelle mesure prévoyez-vous
bonjour monsieur le pardon j'ai là le
ministre en tant que ministre du
numérique quelle mesure prévoyez-vous
pour gérer les risques potentiels liés à
l'apparition des robots conversationnels
tel que la protection de la vie privée
des citoyens et la garantie de la
transparence de l'information diffusée
par ces technologies c'est réellement
une question que tchadipiti vous pose
j'ai faut-il que je consulte chat gepy
faut que vous me répondiez
l'Union européenne s'est engagé dans
dans une réflexion sur l'encadrement de
l'intelligence artificielle au sens
large pour identifier certains usages
pour lesquels l'intelligence
artificielle est interdite d'autres pour
lesquelles elle doit être régulée ou les
fournisseurs d'intelligence artificielle
de système basé sur l'intelligence
artificielle doivent déclarer aux
autorités un certain nombre de choses et
en particulier la la nature le
fonctionnement de leurs algorithmes et
la nature des jeux de données des jeux
de d'information à partir desquelles ces
algorithmes ont été conçus et puis
d'autres usages pour lesquels notamment
dans le cadre du divertissement
intelligence artificielle et
parfaitement libre pendant la
négociation de ce de ce texte la France
a poussé deux idées fortes la première
c'est qu'il ne fallait pas que la
régulation étouffe l'innovation en
Europe parce que nous ne voulons pas que
dans 10 ans quand l'intelligence
artificielle occupera une place
importante dans nos vies que nous soyons
dépendants de solutions d'intelligence
artificielle conçues aux États-Unis ou
en Chine il nous faut donc permettre
compris à nos entreprises et la deuxième
chose que la France a addite et qu'elle
a obtenu c'est que ce qu'on appelle les
intelligences artificielles à vocation
générale parce que
j'ai pété que tchat j'ai pété soit
intégré dans ce règlement européen et ça
c'est important pourquoi parce que chat
j'ai pété nous l'utilisons dans nos vies
quotidiennes pour poser des questions ou
pour faire des tests mais tchat j'ai
pété a surtout vocation à être vendu à
d'autres fournisseurs d'intelligence
artificielle qui ensuite vont se tourner
vers des particuliers ou des entreprises
et il faut que les concepteurs de chat
GPT portent une partie de la
responsabilité de pouvoir déclarer les
la formation etc ceci étant dit et je
finis pour la réponse sur cette question
je ne suis pas sûr que ce règlement
européen aura épuisé toutes les
questions éthiques que soulève des
solutions comme chat GPTD les robots
conversationnels comme on dit des agents
conversationnels les questions de
manipulation de discrimination de
respect de la vie privée et de
déshumanisation de relation entre
l'humain et la machine et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai saisi le
Conseil national pilote pour l'éthique
du numérique une instance créée en 2019
rattaché au Conseil national des tiques
présidé par Jean-François delfresci et
qui travaille sur les questions de
l'éthique du numérique je l'ai saisi
il y a quelques jours pour qu'il puisse
à la lumière de l'arrivée de chat GPT de
sa diffusion puisqu'il y a 100 millions
de personnes qui ont commencé à
l'utiliser pour savoir s'il faut que
certaines de ces questions puis cette
verser au débat public au débat
démocratique pour que nous puissions les
trancher de cette manière il y en a déjà
qui à mon avis sont versés au débat
démocratique les l'économ
écrit il faut voir ces robots comme
faisant partie d'une tendance beaucoup
plus importante la technologie prend en
charge de plus en plus de tâches que
nous tensions réservé aux humains en
français ça veut dire que il a peur que
chat j'ai pété comme vous dites comme
vous dites menace des emplois c'est de
la parano c'est vrai
chat GPT chat GPT je suis pas sûr que à
court terme remplace beaucoup d'emplois
étant donné toutes les erreurs que l'on
peut trouver dans les réponses qui sont
faites aux questions qu'on lui pose mais
à terme ce type de modèle qui vont être
développés non seulement par openéi qui
est la société qui a créé mais aussi par
Google par meta etc ces modèles là
beaucoup d'entreprises françaises vont
européenne par exemple mais nous avons
en France des vraies ressources et en
particulier des talents mais ces modèles
vont prendre une place dans le monde du
travail à à moyen terme et ce qu'ils
vont prendre c'est c'est la place de
certaines des tâches qui sont peut-être
les plus routinières les plus
rébarbatives pour nous permettre si nous
accompagnons cette transition si nous
formons les Françaises et les Français
assez compétences nouvelles de nous
concentrer sur là où l'intelligence
humaine a une valeur ajoutée c'était
l'intelligence
l'intelligence artificielle ne
remplacera pas l'intelligence humaine
elle assistera l'intelligence humaine
mais il va falloir
modifier nos habitudes de travail et il
va falloir accompagner chacune et chacun
dans la prise en main de ces nouveaux
outils qui permettent de se concentrer
sur des tâches sur lesquelles on a plus
de valeur ajoutée et notamment et bien
tout ce que ce type de logiciel n'a
aucune capacité à faire c'est-à-dire un
peu de un peu de l'abstraction mais
aussi la sensibilité humaine qu'il n'est
en aucun cas en capacité de remplacer
bien merci infiniment de nous avoir
éclairé sur vos domaines de numérique je
rappelle que vous êtes ministre délégué
au numérique auprès de Bruno Le Maire
c'est ça